Film Courage: Do you still love Star
Wars now the same way you did when you
first saw it in the theater or wherever you were?
Houston Howard, Transmedia Author/Speaker:
Absolutely I consider myself just a huge Star Wars
fan. I love Star Wars. I am wildly not objective
about Star Wars and it's interesting, I try to be
objective about Star Wars but I find myself loving
it anyway and I’ll go back and I look at Star
Wars and I recently read the script of episode one
of Phantom Menace and it may have been the worst
script I've ever read. It’s like just a really
bad script in my opinion. It was just terrible.
I still love the movie. It's interesting, I
think you look at some artistic decisions. You
watch Black Swan and then you see how did George
Lucas turn Natalie Portman into a bad actress?
How did that even happen? Ewan Gordon McGregor,
Liam Neeson and Natalie Portman, how do you turn
those people into...and Samuel L. Jackson, how do
you turn them into bad actors that are wooden and
stiff? That's hard to do. Would he did that they
like they weren't that great think of the artistic
choice of the second death star in in return of
the jedi I was thinking about that the other day
you have the death star in in the first movie and
then you get to the third movie and the and the
and then the central plot is around a second
death star that that in today's market I think
would be just like laughed at and people would
say it's lazy riding and doesn't doesn't make a
lot of sense but I love it I love I love the
original movies I love the prequel trilogy
I love the new movies that were a mess in a lot of
ways I feel like the rise of skywalker was three
movies shoved into two hours and it was pacing
issues and all this stuff but I still love it and
that's I think the magic of Star Wars is that Star
Wars doesn't have to be perfect it it it taps into
this youthful whimsy this this this your
imagination and and things just take over and and
and it it takes you to this childlike place where
you don't have to be objectively filmmakery when
you watch Star Wars right and and of course I want
the movies to be good and of course you want the
craft to be great but Star Wars is Star Wars and
and and i'm still a huge fan i'm a fan of what
they're doing on the streaming stuff with the
mandalorian and everything else but for me Star
Wars is is is is like an old box and some like an
old empty box and me as a dad I have a seven year
old and a and a six month old and it's interesting
like i'll look at an empty box as an old empty box
but a kid looks at that empty box and it becomes
a spaceship or it becomes a carriage or it becomes
a tank or it becomes a castle or becomes all of
those in the course of 25 minutes right I think
Star Wars is like that old empty box to to some
filmmakers and writers and artists and critics
they say that's that's there's nothing special
about that that's not great I don't get it it's
just a box but for me when I look at Star Wars
I look at at it like the seven-year-old looking
at the empty box no that's not a box that's that's
that's that's an airplane right that's a spaceship
and and and it takes a different lens to look
through it and so I am I am unabashed of of
of my love for epi for for uh the last jedi right
which is the most divisive Star Wars film ever
ryan johnson's uh episode nine I loved it I
didn't love everything about it but I loved it
that I loved I loved the rise of skywalker I loved
it did I love everything about it of course not
do I love everything about about return
of the jedi of course not but I still
love the movie as a whole I think we've
the fandom has gotten to a point of this
deconstructionism of of they people pick on things
and they say this doesn't I mean think about
with game of thrones and game of last season
of game of thrones gave us the battle battle
of winterfell gave us one of the most dramatic
interesting coolest episodes of tv ever filmed
ever in history and the only thing people could
talk about the next day was the coffee cup they
left in the scene and because that's today's
thing like that's just the way the internet is
that's just the way twitter is and and people
like to deconstruct it and say oh that's lazy
or they drop they they they they fumbled the
landing or whatever they didn't end it right
jj abrams didn't do this right he didn't get this
character right I don't like how ryan johnson did
luke skywalker in this and they nitpick and
nitpick and yeah and things things could be
different things aren't perfect and we don't
love everything but ultimately I i'm i'm a fan
and I love it because it's just it's it's escapism
and and and I try honestly as a professional and
I think all of us professionals understand
how difficult it is to make anything and
how like it's a miracle that any movie ever gets
made ever and so I've i've learned to even look at
quote-unquote bad films and still appreciate them
like wow they actually made that even though it's
terrible and I wasn't they didn't necessarily
enjoy it they still made it and the fact that
the the fact that that that anything gets made
i'm gonna appreciate it and if I can't do better
than that I try not to criticize it and say
that's garbage or that's lazy or whatever
again I don't love everything about it but
ultimately I look I look at I look at the
Star Wars films and and just with with immense
respect for how they've been able to keep that ip
alive over 60 years or 50 years however long it's
been how much they've been able to scale the brand
how long they've been able to sustain the fan
community and create the culture that they have
to continue to to push artistic boundaries of
what they're doing with the mandalorian and
the volumetric capture stage that they they built
and and just the storytelling in the mandalorian
what they're doing what they're doing now with
all the crossover stuff that that one on Disney
plus is absolutely incredible you have somebody
like a character like ahsoka tano i'm gonna get
Star Wars nerdy for a second yeah but you
have a character like ahsoka tano who is a
character from the clone wars animated series
that they then pull into a different animated
series Star Wars rebels that they then pull
into a live-action series of the mandalorian
and cast a live-action actress and now gonna spin
her off to her own live-action series on Disney
plus what they're doing from a trans me in a trans
media sense it's just really super interesting
and and how they revived the Star Wars they say
revive the star it's not like it was dead but
like the way they brought Star Wars back in front
of culture with baby yoda and and now we know as
grosgu but but ever like everybody was talking
about baby yoda just the cultural sensation of
baby yoda it's just really smart interesting
choices that they make and especially now start
they just they have something now called
Star Wars visions where they it's it's it's
animated short films that are all done created
in the manga style so you like japanese animation
is all done in with with manga creators telling
manga stories in the Star Wars universe that are
very much catered to to a completely new market
a younger market a more eastern market where Star
Wars hasn't been able to really get a foothold
as a brand very much and and and and it works and
it's good and it's in it and it's it's powerful
storytelling and so I appreciate them as a fan
I appreciate them as a filmmaker and I appreciate
them as somebody who understands how to build
and sustain ip like the way they do it is just a
master class on on how to keep an engine like that
running and not just running but thriving in the
midst of multiple multiple decades this really is
a tremendous thing and it all goes back to how
George Lucas created and built the whole thing
it's really like he he approached it in a unique
way and they've continued to keep that going do
you think dividing the fandom is by design I don't
think it's by design I think it's I think it's a
byproduct of today's toxic fandom that
is just a thing that that goes on now
but I i think if you were to criticize lucasfilm
for something it's it's with the movies they
they didn't listen to the fandom not saying
that Star Wars movie the Star Wars fans should
decide what's in the Star Wars movies i'm
i'm very much certain that if Star Wars fans
somehow collectively decided what the
next Star Wars movie was going to be
it would be terrible there is artistic integrity
and autonomy with the filmmakers but if you look
at somebody like Kathleen Kennedy kathleen kennedy
is she's an old school filmmakers filmmaker she's
an old school filmmakers producer the the way
she used to produce old steven spielberg stuff
and she's very much a filmmaker's producer
she likes to let the filmmakers run and
make great movies and and I think part of
the misstep of of the the latest trilogy
has been in her letting the
filmmakers kind of run with their own
visions and the lego blocks don't fit together
with the trilogy as well and not really being in
tune with the fandom and and and what the fandom
the directions and what the expectations are and
and being able to set the expectations with
with the fandom and and not that you can please
everybody of course you can't but but in some with
something like Star Wars you just can't approach
it in the way you would in the other movie it's
just a whole other organism that you have to
understand the fans are part of the process
now and and setting expectation and avoiding
cognitive dissonance is a really important thing
with with with understanding how fandoms work so
if I if if if if I was if I were to go to the
south of france for a vacation and and I get
there and it's overcast and rainy and cold and
super expensive and everybody's grouchy and and
not very nice I would come back from that vacation
very upset and frustrated wasn't a great vacation
but if I go to new york city and it's overcast
and cold and rainy and really expensive and
everybody's grouchy guess what that's new york
city like i'm not like i'm not frustrated that
a bit that's the new york city experience the
difference is what's your expectation and so if
if I have the expectation it's going to be warm
and bright and sunny and everybody's going to be
sweet and nice and it's the opposite of that
that's where frustration kicks in because of
cognitive dissonance and so managing expectation
of audiences and and and letting them know the
direction that we're going and some of the things
we're trying to achieve and and and letting them
have a voice and and and and making them part
of the conversation and and and helping shape
some sort of expectation in their mind not saying
plot points or things like that or big reveals i'm
sorry it's just general direction that that
the franchise is heading that conversation
is super important to have with fandoms
today and that's something that lucasfilm
and kathleen kinley didn't do when it came to
the the the sequel trilogy as they call it and
and you and you see now all of a sudden when
when I think everybody was on board for force
awakens but then when ryan johnson did the last
jedi and luke skywalker didn't act like people
thought luke skywalker should act and there were
some choices that were made that were surprising
and didn't go that and then then all of a sudden
rises skywalker went in some different directions
that started to divide the fandom and and some
people loved it some people hated it and we they
all couldn't agree and but but there wasn't
enough community building I think they just
took the community for granted I think they
said as long as we give them a Star Wars movie
everything will work out and it just it didn't
didn't work but that being said Kathleen Kennedy
gave us the mandalorian Kathleen Kennedy gave
us rogue one which I think is one of the best
Star Wars movies ever made uh Kathleen Kennedy
has is giving us she brought in john favreau for
for the mandalorian she's the the book of boba
fett she's overseeing all that like katherine
kennedy I think has done more good things
than the bad things it just so happens
that I think the misstep was on the biggest
stage with the new trilogy because Star Wars
really is built around trilogies and that's the
legacy of Star Wars and so you have to nail those
they I think we could fumble some Disney plus
series and the fans would gripe about it but
you can't fumble the the the the the trilogy and
i'm not saying it's complete fumble but it wasn't
it wasn't as good as it should have been from
a from a from a trilogy standpoint there should
have been she should have made sure that there was
there was a creative vision and a creative plan
that was that was in place before
they even started the first movie
and they were able to see that through so there
would be lego blocks that connected in the best
possible way make sure the community was on
board and understood the direction they were
going to they were going in to avoid the cognitive
dissonance and that didn't happen so that being
said the movie is still wildly successful but but
ultimately it created this division the fan base
but the mandalorian kind of brought them all back
together and so even though you may hate last jedi
and I love last jedi we can all high five on baby
yoda right and and so that's been that's been I
think a really good thing for the fandom is is
the mandalorians kind of brought it all back so
should Star Wars ever make another trilogy oh
absolutely I think they should make 100 more
trilogies as long as the market it will bear it as
long as Star Wars fans want more Star Wars movies
absolutely if Star Wars fans don't want more Star
Wars movies then then no right the market should
decide whether they should make more or whether
they shouldn't make more I i would love I would
love more right and I think we're gonna I think
we're gonna we're gonna see more I think we're
gonna see stand-alone movies and I think we're
gonna see trilogies I think the trilogies will
be approached differently moving forward but
patty jenkins is coming in she did wonder woman
both the wonder woman movies she's doing a rogue
squadron film which should be great kevin feige
is going to be producing a a Star Wars film
taekwontiti is writing his own Star Wars movie
ryan johnson uh from what I've read still has Star
Wars a trilogy that they're gonna allow him to do
which will probably be super divisive and but I
think if you give him a trilogy that's just his
it works a lot better right especially after this
what we're seeing like his success in knives out
and things like that since then I think has has
changed his star power a little bit to where
I think people trust trust him a little bit
more with it than maybe they did before at
least they should because knives out is great
and knives out too should be great as well
i'm a big ryan chancellor friend if you go back
to brick and things like that he's just great but
but yeah absolutely 100 they should they should
continue to make trilogies they can they should
continue to make standalone they should continue
to do animation they should should continue to do
live action series games board games video
games novels what they're doing right now
in in the publishing space is super super super
impressive with what they call the high republic
the high republic part of the universe which is
thousands of years before the prequel trilogy you
go back to the the days where the jedi were like
the the the wild west sheriff's in in sort of this
this really rough part of the galaxy and and
they they have coordinated with multiple authors
and multiple comic creators and multiple novelists
and and and they all have have worked out
this tremendously publishing plan where they're
where they're publishing adult novels why a
novels junior novels comic books that all tie in
together to create one big publishing experience
that then is going to spin into a live-action
show for Disney plus that's going to be
called the acolyte which is going to be set in the
high republic era which they just also announced
a new video game that's going to be set in the
the knights of the old republic supposedly set in
the similar time and and probably then probably
become the new trilogy I think part of the
the the problem with the sequel trilogy outside
of the lego blocks is not fitting together because
the plan wasn't installed is you're dealing with
legacy characters that everybody cares about
luke skywalker and han solo and princess leia
and chewbacca and so all of a sudden everybody
has ideas of how those characters should go
and how and what we should do with them you
can't kill that one but you should kill that one
things like that I think I think any new trilogy
needs to unhitch from those legacy
characters and establish new characters and
news stories in different parts of the galaxy
dealing with different things and so you don't
have all that legacy baggage that's why I
think the mandalorian worked is because it
was it was it didn't have to deal with any of
those legacy characters and we all like okay
we don't have any expectations anymore of of how
luke skywalker's story should end we can all just
enjoy this new ride together and so I think
I i think that will probably be the way of a
new trilogy but but who knows I mean right I mean
who knows the way it'll go I mean if Star Wars is
sort of built around this idea of of of pulling
in the crossover of different things and taking
minor characters from the background of this
one scene and a new hope and now we're gonna
make that a major character in the mandalorian and
and that's cool for fandoms and there's this very
incestuous approach to Star Wars which maybe is
not the best word to use but maybe is the right
word since luke and leia actually kiss and then
you find out their brother and sister which is all
again one of those weird things that we just love
Star Wars so we overlook but but but it's very
very connected and the way they dine with the way
lucas always dynamically connected all the stuff
and the lucasfilm with the with what they call the
story group which is the the team that oversees
the connection between all the different video
games and movies and tv shows how it all works
together so if there will always be connection
and crossover but I think moving past the legacy
characters is gonna is gonna create it create a
more forgiving perspective on it on a new trilogy
that they didn't have with the sequel trilogy
even though they had different protagonists
the fact that luke skywalker was in there and
han solo was in there and jj killed han solo
in force awakens and it just like freaked so many
people out even though I thought it was a kind of
a powerful interesting moment uh in the movie
really just made a lot of people mad because
they love han solo and they we think they should
never die Star Wars fans are weird like that but
it but it's it's I think unhitching from those
characters is really gonna be the way forward so
I really look forward to all the new content
whether whether it's it's it's it's it's feature
films or not what I do think though is that
they'll really manage the windowing of the
release of the films it was getting to a point
where they were they were releasing one a year and
that I think was was difficult especially when you
put in the marvel movies in the mix black panther
and solo were released just a few weeks apart and
and there there was some Disney cannibalization
going on I think the way forward for Star Wars
movies is just spacing them out more right
especially if you have the Disney plus content and
the publishing content and the the game content to
kind of go between the movies to help continue
to feed the fan base between those big releases
I think that's going to make them more special and
because once you start kind of pumping them out so
much they start to lose their shine a little bit
and especially when it comes to the interconnected
stories it's just it's just they become
less special so windowing I think will help.
What are your thoughts on this video?